nimmt bundespräsident walter steinmeier
christoph metzelder jetzt das
bundesverdienstkreuz weg die
ehrenauszeichnung hat christoph
metzelder bereits am vierten dezember
2017 für sein engagement zur
unterstützung sozialer projekte bekommen
mittlerweile wird aber gegen ihn wegen
kinderpornografie vorwürfen ermittelt
wie erfassen den fallen metzelder noch
einmal für sie zusammen
anfangs 17 bei 2009 10 hatten lka
fahnder metzelder beim trainer lehrgang
an der sportschule hennef abgefangen um
durchsuchungsbeschlüsse zu vollstrecken
sie durchsuchten unter anderem sein haus
in düsseldorf stellten dort computer und
laptops sicher nach bild-informationen
soll metzelder zwei frauen aus hamburg
und dem münsterland mindestens 15
nachrichten mit möglicherweise
kriminellem inhalt geschickt haben
metzelder blieb nach der durchsuchung
auf freiem fuß ja und bei mir im studio
ist jetzt hans jörg vehlewald wir wollen
darüber sprechen über das
bundesverdienstkreuze war es christoph
meter der männer bekommen hat wir haben
eine anfrage gestellt an das
bundespräsidialamt
wir haben sie gefragt warum hat er das
überhaupt bekommen
die offizielle antwort darauf ist dass
christoph metzelder
am vierten dezember 2017 für sein
engagement zur unterstützung sozialer
projekte unter anderem als behinderten
gute botschafter für die
fußball-weltmeisterschaft und für die
unterstützung durch die gründung der
christoph metzelder stütze stiftung zur
unterstützung für kinder und
jugendlichen in den bereichen bildung
ausbildung integration bekommen hat da
fällt zum nächsten mal auf dass das wort
kinder und jugend da relativ häufig
auftaucht die nächste frage über
zunächst immer gestellt haben war hat er
im erzählen jetzt vielleicht von sich
aus auf grund der vorwürfe sein
bundesverdienstkreuz schon zurückgegeben
antworten nein es bislang nicht
zurückgegeben worden und dann haben wir
auch noch mal offiziell gefragt wie ich
es eigentlich die rechtslage wie kann
man eigentlich an solche
bundesverdienstkreuz entziehen ist das
überhaupt vorgesehen und dafür weiß das
bundespräsidialamt für steinmeier
auf den paragrafen 4 des gesetzes über
titel orden und ehrenzeichen auch das
gibt es in deutschland und dort ist die
möglichkeit heißt es hier eröffnet eine
auszeichnung zu entziehen wenn sich der
ordensträger durch sein verhalten
insbesondere richtet durch das begehen
einer entehren den straftat der
verliehenen auszeichnung als unwürdig
erweist
das gilt generell unabhängig von der
person metzelder in diesem fall prüft
dann der bundes das bundespräsidialamt
bei bekanntwerden eines solchen
verhaltens stets ob die voraussetzungen
für die entziehung des ordens vorliegen
und dann kommt noch einen satz hinten
dran dies gilt insbesondere dann wenn
die vorwürfe über die verdient auch auch
die verdienste betreffen für die der
ordensträger also herr metzelder
ausgezeichnet wurde da denkt man jetzt
wieder da im ersten satz hieß es ja
kinder und jugendliche das hat also eine
gewisse brisanz darauf weist das
schreiben durchaus hin dann haben wir
konkret gefahr läuft ein anerkennung ab
erkennungsverfahren da heißt es dann
offizielle antwort die entwicklungen in
dem derzeit geführten strafverfahren
gegen christoph metzelder werden vom
bundespräsidialamt genau beobachtet das
ist mehr als man normalerweise in
solchen stellungnahmen bekommt und gibt
es noch mal den hinweis haben sie jedoch
verständnis dass im hinblick auf den im
ordens wesen durchgängig geltenden
grundsatz der vertraulichkeit über die
einhaltung eines solchen verfahrens
einleitung eines solchen verfahrens
keine auskunft erteilt werden kann
das heißt wir reden nicht öffentlich
darüber trotz allem fällt schon auf die
formulierung wird genau beobachtet wie
ist das normale verfahren immer dann
wenn ein ordensträger
bundesverdienstkreuzes in ein spielrecht
rechtmäßig verurteilt ist und dabei eine
strafe von mehr als einem jahr oder
bestimmte andere strafrechtliche dinge
eine rolle spielen immer dann wenn das
urteil fertig ist muss tatsächlich das
gericht oder eine zuständige behörde an
den bundespräsidenten melden
sie ist einer der hat dieses kreuz
bekommen und er hat jetzt etwas getan
was dem ansehen des
bundesverdienstkreuzes und damit auch
des staates zuwider laufen könnte
das ist letztlich dann der fall wenn zum
beispiel herr metzelder
in sachen kinderpornos verurteilt werden
sollte womöglich dann zu einer strafe
von mehr als einem jahr gibt es
automatisch eine meldung an das
bundespräsidialamt oder sonstige
behörden und dann wird ein solches die
prüfung sozusagen der aberkennung
eingeleitet letztlich sagt die
formulierung wir werben wir beobachten
das sehr genau dass tatsächlich in
diesem fall die augen sehr genau auf den
fall metzelder gerichtet sind
gab es denn einen solchen oder ähnlichen
fall schon mal dass er ordensträger das
wieder zurückgeben mussten also
aberkannt wurde es letztlich nur in zwei
fällen obwohl vieles uns jedenfalls
bekannt
das waren zwei fälle die lange
zurückliegen und da wurde bekannt dass
diejenigen in der nazi zeit unter
anderem bei der ig farben als der
wirtschaft viel über tätig waren ein
anderer war ss hauptsturmführer dass es
alle sehr sehr lange her aber es gibt
die fälle zum beispiel von peter hardt
dem erfinder der arbeitsmarktreform und
klaus zumwinkel ex-postchef die haben
sich beide entschlossen bevor es dann zu
einer aberkennung kommt dazu
entschlossen bis einfach von sich aus
zurück zu geben um zu verhindern dass es
eine peinliche nummer gibt diskussionen
darüber gab es im rahmen von der
verurteilung von alice schwarzer in
sachen steuerhinterziehung und das
gleiche bei fifa chef sepp blatter der
auch ein bundesverdienstkreuz hat
da wurde auch diskutiert ob es ab zu
erkennen sei nach unserem wissen ist es
aber nicht aberkannt worden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren